welcome back to cbs saturday morning we
begin this half hour with a growing
problem in rural america the latest
census report finds that 60 million
americans nearly one in five live in
rural areas and according to the centers
for disease control they tend to be
older sicker and poorer than the average
american now they're at even greater
risk a report that finds there are not
enough ambulances to help in an
emergency cbs news transportation
correspondent errol barnett has the
story
in southwest wyoming there are only four
ambulances for an area the size of
connecticut ten thousand square miles
and ron gotti not
but having available emergency here
gives new meaning to the word
one of our biggest stress factors
is the distance
the distance we travel the distance we
transport patients
brian eveleth is one of 12 on
sweetwater's full-time emt crew i've
transported critically ill patients back
from the scene for an hour and a half
especially if it's snowing it just takes
a long time to get there and
you know i'm going hollering at my
driver saying he's getting worse and the
driver is hollering back the roads are
getting worse too and i had to slow down
when a call comes in there's no telling
how long it will take to get to the one
hospital in the county with a 24 7
emergency room
we have two major interstates that run
through the state of wyoming and those
traveling along those 100 mile gaps in
the state of wyoming have no idea of the
crisis that emergency medical services
is in rural ambulance service is in its
own emergency according to a study from
the rural policy institute it found long
distances and challenging terrain
prolong emergency response times there's
not enough money to make ambulance
service viable and there's a lack of
regional ems plans to coordinate
services a lack of ems has a direct
impact on the life expectancy of these
rural residents based in washington d.c
alan morgan is executive director of the
national rural health association when
you say this could be a contributing
factor to the mortality rate worsening
in rural areas it's a really
shocking statement since 1980
while we've seen increased life
expectancy among urban populations we've
seen declining life expectancy among
rural populations and not having access
to timely ems services has a direct
impact on your chances of survival
compounding the problem is the fact that
39 states wyoming among them do not
designate ambulance service as essential
which means government support available
to other essential services like police
and fire services are not available for
ambulances we are viewed
not as health care providers
but as transportation providers we're
not just an expensive taxi we deliver
life saving skills i have critical care
paramedics that do miraculous things the
stresses on rural ambulance providers is
coming as aging baby boomers need the
most nearly one-third of the nation's
rural medical services were found to be
an immediate operational jeopardy in
penrose colorado ambulance service was
suspended in july with the fire
department posting the community cannot
assume that an ambulance will be
available for a call to service
in montana a department of public health
and human services report found 34
percent of ambulances occasionally
cannot respond to a call 10 wyoming
ambulance companies are on the verge of
closing down
including ron gotti's the cardiac
monitors that we have to buy are thirty
thousand dollars apiece it's an
expensive place to get into there's no
profit margins the problem with rural
ems is it's a numbers game and for rural
america the numbers just don't add up
what role do insurance companies play
yeah unfortunately for a lot of these
rural communities it comes down to the
payment issue it's so very important for
insurance companies to step up and do
their due part to ensure access to care
for rural americans when it comes to ems
services we're only reimbursed if we're
transporting people
so if i go out and i help you
and i wrap up your wounds and i take
care of you and you tell me i don't want
to go to the hospital
then we don't make any money the
sweetwater ambulance company remains in
business thanks to support from the
county's supervisors but that lasts one
more
year so very soon there could be no
ambulance service around the rock
springs wyoming area they go and they
they risk their lives and they they do
things that other people won't or can't
do to make the difference for a human
life well we need a hero
we need heroes now for cbs saturday
morning errol barnett washington
it's hard to imagine ambulance services
not being designated as essential right
as as they are or not
ambulances for every ten thousand square
miles it's crazy yeah with that he said
it's a numbers game but we're talking
about lives yeah that should matter
first one and the the other one 100 mile
gaps
in between it's just frightening